elle était partie du premier coup mais
là rien
alors ça c'est la tête de delco je vais
voir tenez-vous bien
c'était pas la tête de delco c'était la
durée
ça commence à aller mieux là
c'est pas la tête de delco c'est la
durite et Janine elle me fait bah ça
m'étonne pas à chaque fois c'est le même
truc on croit que c'est la tête de Nico
et puis finalement c'est la durite oh et
ça soulage bien
essayez de bouger doucement votre tête
ne sentez rien aucune douleur non
parfait
passez vous le sinus en expirant
doucement
ça vous fait mal oui ça me lance encore
un peu on va arranger ça donc je répare
la durite et la Janine elle me fait ah
bah dis donc le gigot il va plutôt être
trop cuit
si un nouveau
ça fait plus mal du tout
parfait vous pouvez vous rhabiller c'est
terminé merci Docteur je dois combien
nous venons d'assister à votre
consultation je crois que vous êtes un
des tout premier médecin à pratiquer la
culothérapie c'est exact la culothérapie
est une technique très nouvelle qui
n'est pas encore très répandue je pense
que nous sommes à peu près une douzaine
de kilothérapeutes sur Paris et en quoi
consiste exactement la cryothérapie la
culothérapie est un traitement tout
nouveau pour guérir les céphalées ce
qu'on appelle couramment les migraines
qu'elle soit d'origine ophtalmique et
bateau biliaire voire même botulique
mais alors cette méthode curative peut
s'appliquer à tous les patients atteints
de céphalées non non
mais alors comment reconnaissez-vous les
les patients que vous pouvez soigner
grâce à la cryothérapie
en général Dieu nous trouver en disant
cause à mon cul ma tête est malade
bien je voudrais docteur vous poser
juste une dernière question je
vous ne vous sentez pas bien
excusez-moi
nous avons des journées épuisantes oui
je peux faire quelque chose pour vous
demander
ce serait pas de refus merci beaucoup
de cuisine parce que une recette de
cuisine les contes de fées
[Musique]
aux raisins de préférence il vaut mieux
avoir un faitout en cuivre et un kilo de
Muscat ah oui ça soulage bien et une
caille bien fraîche oh ça fait du bien
bien fraîche la caille oh là là que
c'est bon et alors le mieux c'est de la
larder
vous la mettez dans le fait tout en vous
êtes doué dans lequel vous avez fait
fondre 200 g de beurre oh c'est
miraculeux bien frais aussi comme la
caille le beurre
[Musique]